So this is the general formula for any ellipse. The center doesn't have to be
at the origin and the values of h and k determine what our center is. Notice
too, that if our center is the origin, then the value of h would be 0 and the
value of k would be 0. If we subtract 0 from x, we'll still have x. So we'll
just have x squared over a squared plus y squared over b squared equal to 1.
This is the first general formula we saw for any ellipse centered at the
origin. I mean, this was the second general formula we saw for any ellipse
centered at h comma k. Keep in mind that if these signs are negative then both
the values of h and k will be positive. Whereas these signs are positive then
that means the values of h and k are negative.